foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Marcus Spears the big swagoo you can
catch him on NFL live Monday through
Friday and the mothership at 4 eastern
dannerlovsky mean at times Ryan Clark
and Laura Rutledge the difference
between your quarterback being cocky and
being confident is what
Taki is when he's trying to build
himself up to be something he's not
confident is when he knows he's gonna
ball every time he steps on the field
Joe burrow is confident but is he
absolutely not cocky to me
um I think and DPA got a lot to do with
the work that you put in to be good
right
um you know some people interpret it
that way but I don't think
cocky is one of those things where
not not for the public outside of the
locker room but the guys in the locker
room if you cocky you ain't leading if
you're confident we'll follow you and
for a quarterback that's the most
important thing we don't want a
non-confident quarterback and there's a
line to where when you think you are you
are him the Young The Young Folks now
Dan DP say him you are empathy that
means you are that guy
um so you want to feel like you want to
feel like your quarterback is that but
you don't want him to be cocky okay how
many how many timothies
are in the NFL at quarterback
um
let me see one two
three
you can say their names out loud you got
Pat obviously you got
um Joe burrow
Lamar Jackson
Thomas still him I just think Tom age is
starting to like show itself a little
bit too much
Josh Allen
absolutely Josh Allen
um
it's not that many it's not that many
days
I think that is I think that is
um there's inconsistency to his empathy
you know what I mean
um but what's the disconnect with Dak
Prescott like what is preventing him
from being a top five quarterback
um
inconsistency man and then two
DP he's he's more scrutinized than
anybody because we know what team he
plays for so half the world I have to
have the country will want him to fail
anyway
um but no man it has to be a consistency
in what you do like all of the guys
and not just him winning in performance
as well like I think look I think Justin
Herbert is super talented I think
sometimes we get a bit carried away
with Justin Herbert
um I think Josh Allen is Elite because
Josh Allen has consistently won football
game
um I think Lamar Jackson is Elite it's
just done a different way he
consistently wins football games year in
and year out
um you know and Pat and Aaron and Tom
obviously in a class of their own Tom is
the greatest winner of all time he's the
goat in football not the most talented
um so it's just different you gotta have
variation and Nuance when you talk about
these quarterbacks if it's a Young
quarterback in the NFL that I would want
if somebody was to nail me down and say
give me mortgage you got a chance to
take one of these quarterbacks I'm not
talking about the three I mentioned that
already not Pat Pat is the obvious
answer you're gonna take Patrick Mahal
um Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady I'm not
putting them in that category
without a shadow of a doubt the first
name that's gonna come off my board is
Joe burrow
I was also wondering this if I swapped
Justin Herbert and Dak Prescott I put
Dak on the Chargers put Justin Herbert
on the Cowboys
are we treating them differently
absolutely
absolutely because look man Justin
Herbert see we make these marriages
hindsight right because you think about
all of the things that have transpired
in the NFL when quarterbacks in a
certain situation or where they could go
right Tom is is is phenomenal because he
actually did it when he left New England
we was like damn Tampa a good place to
go they got a good defense good offense
they got guys and it actually worked
um but I think if you took that and put
them in a smaller Market
her cousin skates by because he in
Minnesota
like you could you imagine and Kirk
Cousins gets scrutinized I think
unfairly at times I think he's a really
good quarterback but if he was in Dallas
it would be worse
that can Kirk Cousins are pretty much
the same guys
oh you would compare those two
absolutely okay absolutely but you got
to be a closer
that's all DP see that's why you that's
why you the magic man at this because
no matter how much fans
want to admit it
at the end of a football season
all of those stats and touchdowns and
all of that don't matter
because what did we talk about at the
end of this year we talked about
Matt Stafford at the end of the Tampa
game when they had to make plays we
talked about Tom Brady and the reason
why we think Tom Brady is the goat is
because of moments it ain't
statistically
we think about him as the goat because
of coming back against the Atlanta
Falcons making drives to get Adam
Vinatieri in position to kick a field
goal seeing what he did
um his defense led him to the the
championship when he was in Tampa but he
still had to he had to make a critical
drive against Green Bay that's how we
remember guys like as much as we lord
Aaron Rodgers
we always talk about he only got one
Super Bowl and the reason why it's
poignant to talk about Aaron Rodgers
with only one Super Bowl is because
we've seen him at times with the ball in
his hand not come through yeah right so
it's it's really it really boils down to
and and and everybody that's why we say
Tom Brady is the goal because everybody
is chasing those moments
DP I made you on this question
if I put these guys on the draft board
Tom Brady will be the last quarterback
you take
if we was just if we was drafting off
Talent
and obviously we know he went late
rounds in the draft right if we were
just drafting off Talent the one thing
you can't quantify until it actually
happens how are you in critical moments
right and that's why he's the goat but I
would draft Patrick Mahomes before him I
would draft Aaron Rodgers before him I
would draft Joe burrow before him but
knowing what we know now over a 20-year
period we know that Tom and what we talk
about all the time is how clutch he's
been we don't talk about the 5 000 yard
seasons or the high the high number of
touchdowns we don't talk about him
scrambling and making some Dynamic play
we say oh my God the scariest thing in
the world is Tom Brady with the football
in his hand at the end of a game
he's the big swagu Marcus Spears NFL
analyst you can see him on NFL live
Monday through Friday Dan orlovsky Mina
kimes Ryan Clark and Laura Rutledge the
cowboy situation you have Brett Maher
obviously lacking confidence so how do
you bolster that confidence you bring in
another kicker for practice
help help me you know from the outside
looking in
this can't be helping Brett Maher it
doesn't help him at all I I listen but
but DP this is the part of the business
that nobody likes to talk about and we
don't like to acknowledge
like when I put I was playing in the
league for nine years there were there
would be dudes on Wednesdays coming on
the field after we walked off of
practice to see if one of them could
take somebody's job
like that's that's the reality of the
NFL yeah like if you didn't feel like a
unit or an individual was performing
up to a standard or a level they were
trying to find the guy that could get to
that standard or that level now DP you
missed four extra points
and we know that a lot of times in these
playoffs these games come down to those
just you know we we would have hearken
back if Timber would have made a run
and if the game would have been close
Tampa didn't even have to win if the
game would have been close we'd talk
about well he left four points on the
scoreboard
you know he left for four points out
there he missed some kicks against Tampa
the first game of the season that nobody
remembers because that was a 19-3 game
but he had some opportunities in that
game look man it's a doggy dog world up
here coaches jobs are based on
performance from their players and there
is no critic more critical time
did to have a kicker in the in the
playoffs we know we know how important
it is when he just started covering
football but you're right it don't do a
damn thing for his confidence but I
don't care about his confidence I care
about the ball going through the
uprights we have Jason Garrett on First
Tower I said if did you ever yell at a
kick her he goes no because there's a
fragile nature to them you put your the
only player on the team you put your arm
around if they make a mistake you put
your arm around every everybody else it
feels like can get yelled at what DP
think about this because I've always had
this
um
this sentiment towards kickers I never
really liked them a lot be honest with
you
um when we used to be in Camp in Dallas
they would be playing golf they'll come
do their special teams thing they'll go
play Golf the golf course in Oxnard was
right behind the practice field they'll
be on the golf course we'll be out there
damn they're about to die taking on
double teams okay so I never had a great
affinity for them the Affinity comes
from do you deliver in those moments
where we need you the most I remember a
game I don't remember the kicker's name
but I remember a game Larry Allen met
the kicker out there on the field and
damn near choked them to death okay so
it's not that it's not that we love you
if you're Justin Tucker
okay because you've you've built enough
cachet to miss one yeah right but when
you got these guys man and and they get
a they get a heart it's a hard it's a
hard job and everybody talks about like
the kid from Ohio State
right the in in the in the championship
in the uh semi-final game who missed
that kick when Kirby call that time out
I was sitting next to my wife on the
sofa the kid turned his back to the
field goal and took his helmet off he
was done yeah
that's what Jason Garrett was alluding
to about fragility when it comes to
their mentality because DP the one the
one thing that I give them is it's like
a lot of times in their career it's like
going up to the free throw line and you
gotta make these two yeah you know what
I'm saying it's the guys
85 in the first three and a half
quarters and shoot 75 percent in the
final half quarter Paulie do you have
the game that uh Marcus is talking about
yeah I think it's 2005 San Francisco
versus Dallas at San Francisco Bledsoe
throws a touchdown Jose Cortez misses an
extra point and Larry Allen Larry Allen
looks like he's gonna pile drive him
dude I'm telling you it was because
because
I'm telling you bro it's a very it's a
very uh it's a very uh difficult
relationship to manage let me just say
that uh the Brock Purdy
experience I was gonna say experiment
but it's not an experiment it's the
experience here
what has stood out that you think is
actually sustainable for him in his
career Boys Boys Boys Boys Boys
and I think that's one of the best
traits any quarterback has to have
um
you can always punch holes in the game
of a quarterback we can find the flaws
we watch film my crew on NFL live if you
want a quarterback to be the worst
quarterback we can find the plays to
prove it right that's our lobsky yeah
that's that's Dan FDO job
um and he does that with that Collide
which is why we fight so much
um
they threw two interceptions but he
threw five touchdowns no we're gonna
focus on these two interceptions all
right no but but man it's um
it is one of them it's it's just a
yes okay it's just something right and
and look we can all acknowledge that
he's in a great situation with Kyle
Shanahan as a coach and he's in a great
offense with guys that you don't have to
throw the ball 50 times a game 15 20
yards downfield in order to make it
explosive plays we can acknowledge all
of that we can acknowledge that he he
plays with one of the best defenses well
the best defense in the NFL so there's
not a lot of pressure where you go into
a game thinking you're gonna have to
score 35 or 40 points you got a great
run game like you he's he's in a in a
very
um comfortable position as a quarterback
right
um which is why I used to throw up in my
mouth when people said Jimmy Garoppolo
was leading the 49ers to the Super Bowl
he was not all you had to do was watch
the games he was not
um but he was playing he was
facilitating and and that's what that
actually brought Purdy just now just
gave me an epiphany about Jimmy
Garoppolo Jimmy just did what he needed
to do and that's what Brock Purdy is
doing now the one thing I like about
this kid
he knew that he had a team that was on
the ascend before Jimmy got hurt
he knew where they were where they were
at before he took over the starting spot
and he's facilitated and made a lot of
tremendous plays in his athleticism
brings another element to this offense
that isn't usually there which is the
reason why I thought they drafted Trey
Lance he he's been he's been really good
DP he's been really really good he's
supported by a really good cast of
coaches and players but he's he's done
his job at a at a at a very high level
and he's doing what he's been asked to
do so I give him credit for that am I
putting him in can hell no I heard him I
heard I I I almost fought with a dude on
Twitter talking about Brock Purdy is
special he plays six games
like when you say special about somebody
that means you are putting them in a
category of elite to me that's my
definition let's let's let's let's take
a pause on that right quick and just
acknowledge that the kid has played well
and put his team in a position to win
games
if the Ravens let Lamar Jackson go
finish the sentence the dumbest
franchise in NFL
um or
are you blowing it up and you you're
changing your philosophy as an offense
and that may take a few years to get
going because one you got to identify
the right quarterback too you got to
change the way you coach
um coach offensive football
um would you give him a Deshawn Watson
contract right now just 230 million all
guaranteed absolutely okay because DP
and I'm gonna give you a I'm gonna give
you a reason and you you know we gonna
hang up in the military call let's fight
over this okay
there is no player in the NFL more
valuable to his team than Lamar Jackson
that doesn't mean Lamar Jackson is
better than Patrick Mahomes it doesn't
mean he's better than any other
quarterback that we deemed these top
Elite guys value
Lamar Jackson is the most valuable
player at the position to his particular
team
the Baltimore Ravens are not who we have
seen them to be without Lamar Jackson
now a big part of that is they built it
that way yes
they wanted him to be what he is to that
offense I have screamed and hollered get
this man some wide receivers
get him some weapons Mark Andrews going
to the Hall of Fame because the
Baltimore Ravens ain't got no one I
received and I love Mark Andrews he's a
great tight end not a good one he's a
great tight end and he would go to the
Hall of Fame anyway but I'm being
facetious and making the point that I
would beg anybody to go back since Lamar
Jackson has been in Baltimore and named
one guy on the perimeter that scares you
no I thought they go ahead is Lamar
Jackson the Luka doncic
yeah quarterbacks yes
you get Luca a big man and a couple
shooters
and we know what the conversation gonna
be in the West
no he would have to change his game and
not be so ball dominant he'll be more of
a facilitator but he could adjust to
that and he still would get 30.
but DP there is no way you could look at
football okay
when it in terms of the Baltimore Ravens
and say that team would be this without
Lamar Jackson
there's no way you could do it yeah I
wonder I think they're going to
franchise him and and maybe trading but
and if they if they franchise him
you know a trade I'm I think it would be
in his favor yeah
um but if they franchise him like I said
don't get up the other day go to Cabo
oh just hold out
man what if Zeke Elliott got 90 million
dollars for holding out what you think
no more Jackson gonna do it the Ravens
look man I got a tremendous amount of
respect for for uh bashadi they've
always taken care of their guys and it's
a very precarious situation because
you know you don't want to set a
president that's the business element of
it but I'm focused on the player element
the player that you have is more
valuable to what you do as a franchise
than any other player in the NFL
so maybe we should have a discussion
about the guaranteed money uh good good
to talk to you hopefully I'll see you in
Arizona Super Bowl are you are you there
oh coming home live I'm coming oh oh
whoa yeah
yeah I gotta I gotta give you a hug man
all right pretty I feel like swagging
Swagger wants to do a drop by that's
fabulous and he's going to bring him
wait what what is Timothy Timothy
Timothy Timothy you can use it you can
use it DP yeah DP you hit me you're
you're spitting is what you're doing
right now you know what it is
you know what it is you're smitten yeah
uh thank you again Marcus all right
brother I'll take care man always good
Marcus Spears the big swag who
I
just learned what uh spitting was about
20 minutes ago